wait and see we must  Neiman saying you know if this guy fatty  can do it  why don't I play there should be Forum  of two as well  yeah Knight D5 have you played A5 and  Hans played Bishop E7  yeah the main move for arguably Bishop  C5 when she started doing it also I had  a bit of a had its moment  here after D4 the question was is e  takes D4 does black equalize here move  by move or is this mildly unpleasant  because I think it's been established  How does it go after Knight F6 this is  the position that they have right yeah  some moves here now but 97 Bishop G5 is  maybe the main line  it looks fine for black to me  supposed to be fine but it wasn't wasn't  simple as far as I recall how does this  go Knight C6  3